Russia has TV shows not a huge shock to
anybody they have a Sunday night panel
show called Sunday evening with Vladimir
Solovyov
this past Sunday Russian politician
[ __ ] slovnik on of who's a member of
the Duma which is the Russian
parliamentary body said pretty casually
that Russian intelligence stole the
presidency of the United States in 2016
you think wait a second we would have
heard more about that but most news
outlets were doing wall-to-wall coverage
of the hurricane new Konev statement was
first noticed by Julie Davis Julie Davis
runs a pretty critical of Russia media
monitoring site known as Russia lies and
I could play the clip for you most of
our audience doesn't speak Russian and
we don't know how aggressive Russian
media is with YouTube copyright claims
so we're gonna skip the clip but you can
find it if you go looking for it
and someone in Russia saying this is
something that should make news but it
didn't in the US it's not proof of
anything Putin and the Kremlin have been
pretty much denying these allegations
for a long time but the fact that a
Russian politician mentioned so casually
sort of as part of like a broader
conversation that was going on as kind
of like an obvious admission like well
yeah you know Russian intelligence did
steal the American presidential election
if their goal was to throw America into
chaos then they're doing a really good
job of it and whether this is something
that they would say as a lie in order to
cause more chaos we don't really know
but at this point Pat consider the
various positions of different parties
on Russian meddling in the election now
this is a different question than did
Trump criminally collude with Russia
that's 2 3 4 stage yeah exactly the
question is Russian meddling in the
election Democrats in Congress say
Russia meddled in the election many
Republicans in Congress concede that
Russia meddled in the election separate
question from whether Trump colluded the
intelligence community is unanimous that
Russia meddled in the election we even
have a Russian politician
saying Russia meddled in the election
and yet you still have Trump supporters
saying oh it's fake news well I think
they hear that and just just feel like
well I'm not gonna trust some random
politician
oh no or I'm not gonna trust the
intelligence community because they
deceived us when it came to Iraq or
they're notorious for setting up
dictatorial regimes in developing
countries so I can understand that to
some extent but then on the other side
of the coin who are you siding with
people like Vladimir Putin people like
Donald Trump who was so easily convinced
by Putin and actually wanted to set up
some voting Integrity Commission oh yeah
national Commission actually got out of
a meeting at the g20 look at this other
thing over here let me here's a new
shiny thing for everybody to focus on
don't pay attention to all the stuff
that's happening remember Russia's
number-one objective is weakened the US
make the u.s. look more ridiculous and
less powerful on the world stage and I
was thinking again about brave new world
versus 1984 Neil postman once wrote what
Orwell feared were those who would ban
books
what Aldous Huxley author of brave new
world feared was that there would be no
reason to ban a book for there would be
no one who wanted to read one Orwell
feared those who would deprive us of
information Huxley feared those who
would give us so much that we would be
reduced to passivity and egoism Orwell
feared that the truth would be concealed
from us Huxley feared the truth would be
drowned in a sea of irrelevance Orwell
feared we would become a captive culture
Huxley feared we would become a trivial
culture this and the Russia stuff and
the fake news nonsense from Trump this
is why I believe what we are living
through is much more like brave new
world than it is 1984 the video you just
watched was made possible by support
from you please go to patreon.com slash
david pakman show you can make a pledge
of as little as $1 per month and every
dollar helps to support the work that
we're doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad